horning marre de cette nana là voici
patrick bruel a besoin de courte échelle
au blind test un des baisses avance en
voix bruel mois miel que d'hab
et c'est plutôt mieux patrick bruel
bonsoir entêté géo donc la méditerranée
losc arcade hits a choisi pour le coup
de sirocco
il conte de fées a commencé tu faisais
quoi au club méditerranée
pas de nom par kadima pas choisir en
envoyant au public qui a choisi sur un
casting non il m'a choisi sur une petite
annonce dans france soir
j'étais au lycée j'ai eu une petite
annonce on m'a mis une petite annonce
chez allen présenté à l'audition
l'audition s'est bien passé j'ai tourné
le film pourquoi tu as gagné parce que
tu allais l'accent pieds noirs
non je voi l audition parce que je
pouvais prendre l'accent pieds noirs
j'ai gagné parce que j'ai beaucoup de
chance sûr que je suis arrivé dans une
salle il y avait 80 personnes il était 4
heures l'après-midi des tard j'ai pas
trop envie de rester
je suis resté debout ouais je suis resté
debout il ya frères leurs qualités en
fait dans la salle qui m'a regardé de
loin comme j'étais fou il m'a vu il a
fait tient paulo paulo paulo on cherche
un polo à venir
ils ont fait lire ça fait marrer ça
ressemblait un peu à la famille bennis a
après tu as eu peur de devenir le pied
noir de service
c'est ça tu t'es dit si je continue à
faire des rôles de pieds noirs sont est
infernal non moi je voulais bien faire
les rôles de figurants mais penser qu'on
proposait pas un truc très bien le
deuxième rang de 12e j vous mets
proposés après après le coup de sirocco
ça s'appelait rodriguez au pays des
merguez et youri je me suis barré à
louis là je me suis barré new york
pendant un an
et puis c'est passé plein de choses j'ai
fait plein de rencontres en fait été
élevé par sa mère en arrivant de tlemcen
tulasne tamer beaucoup délictueux
demandez toujours conseil
pourquoi parce qu'on n'a jamais donné de
mauvais
ouais lâché à ta mère te dis nous les
juifs on demande toujours conseil à nos
mamans pourquoi ça tu crois qu'ils à moi
ouais non c'est j'ai pas dis nous les
juifs ont dit non ou dans un journal à
laymont pour moi je n'ai pas là pourquoi
tu crois que c'est différent des autres
tu crois absolument pas différent des
autres
non j'ai pas ont dit qu'elles ont dit
que les orientaux dans le sens de la
famille est impérieux développer les
latins vous dites dans le même article
de loi qui dit que tous toujours ton
étoile de david et que les gens croient
que pub crac
je crois que je graverai ça c'est très
vrai bon c'est vrai ça c'est un
porte-bonheur pour toi tu inquiet en ce
moment quand tu lis dans globe des
histoires d'autant lara ou quand tu le
vois le succès de le pen
je suis inquiet oui j'étais très inquiet
autant-lara les envoyer on lui envoie
une photo à
on a fait une petite photo avec vous
dans un bar monde ans issus terre
voici un petit peu fraîcheur des risques
ont été lavés remisera du film du fils
de lelouch qui ont été tous avec la
kippa comme ça que je les tiens si on
nourrit la photo de couleur rose lui
ferait plaisir
bon bah on en vit la famille l on a vu
des réactions
on n'a pas encore on va voir on sait pas
si elle est d'arriver vous fait quoi
concrètement à part lui envoyer des
photos tu milites dans un un mouvement
dur mais je crois que je lis tous les
jours
quant à vis côté des allemands est
quotidienne ce racisme appelle à présent
comment par exemple c'est à dire je sais
pas aujourd'hui t'as fait quoi par
exemple sur michelin nouvelle racisme
aujourd'hui j'ai tourné mon clip toute
la journée jeux ça se passe comment ça
se passe
c'est pas assez
je peux pas dire ça se passe cassisi jeu
s'il tombe sur quelqu'un que j'estime
devant mais à toi je te demande à part
envoyé des photos autant-lara ce que tu
fais concrètement contre le racisme dans
ta vie quotidienne je sais pas
c'est pas désarçonner ses parages pas
quoi dire concrètement oui concrètement
je joue je me dis je vais aller j'avais
à des meetings j'avais des je parle je
parle aux gens je parlais des je crois
je parle à mon frère c'est vrai
concrètement je votre âge descendent pas
dans ma rue en disant tiens aujourd'hui
concrètement je me bats tout racisme
exemple si je suis sur un quai de gare
et que juin il voit le jour
l'algérien devant moi la gare à monter
dans un train il monte dans les montées
dans l'avant première petite mais
demander ses papiers on va vous
premières captures garde les chefs de
gare dans les films à regarder je les
regarde et il m'a regardé j'ai regardé
et il est passé il ya deux mois et ses
papiers et et agit beaucoup enfin bon un
peu goutte d'eau que tu es rapport avec
le métier sont plutôt bons noms il
faudrait métier qu'on a dit non non je
voyais beaucoup un moment que ça brille
et départ normal je débarque dans ce
métier était content s'abrite partout tu
as envie d'enfin de choses alors qu'ils
habitent à des soirées tu y vas tu aimes
tu as des premières qui va affecter ses
copains mais dans le métier je très peu
vincent lindon propos points évidemment
gérard presgurvic
c'est mais c'est bruno gars un
connecteur j'adore j'ai d'ailleurs tiens
joue tous les soirs en ce moment
parisien wesh promo parce que c'est bien
de promotionner parce que personne n'y a
pas beaucoup de gens qui y vont c'est un
spectacle génial c'est tous les soirs à
18h30 aux pauvres parisiens et je trouve
que c'est bien d'aller voir bruno dire
150 auteurs et d'ailleurs il à ce que
j'ai fait de textes avec huit ans et son
spectacle formidable cassine de la
réflexion d'un discours
voilà chrome os la du disque cette
sécher la promo ça dépend comment les
fêtes
ouais mais pas comment c'est fait puis
ça dépend ce que tu défends j'aime bien
le disque donc allé chanter la chanson
ça me donne pas beaucoup c'est un
tournant ce disque aussi j'espère finir
audition le blind test crois que ça va
être une corvée ou non salo prête une
oreille ça me fait marrer mais je pense
qu'on va à hue et à mort